Europol Europe's intergovernmental law
enforcement agency facilitates exchange
of information between national police
forces on narcotics terrorism and
criminal activities it helps to exchange
the information track down the terrorist
suspects gather the information from the
Member States
and share them with authorities Europol
wasn't able to prevent the attacks in
Paris on November 13th
but remember Europe all can only
function properly when all the Member
States cooperate the key issue here is
interconnectivity I think your apology a
unique position to deliver framework for
more efficient information sharing
because of the multiple relevant
databases we have any piece on member
states are currently negotiating a new
framework for Europol horan quanto
entering big or Elemento with los
estados miembros tendrán muchas mockup
acid a day's para interconnect are con
el roble Europol 10 dramas potentia para
compiled colossal agassi own el que
tienes table feliz en el are a ho numero
uno de Elemento empieza por la palabra
Turismo Eater mina al enumerate Renta
portion of video the Parliament is
asking for greater supervisory powers
over the hague based agency lessons
learnt from the recent terrorist attacks
will weigh in the balance